tell us what you just did with some
famous guys some people may know last
week on the day that wils made that
whole story tell us what just happened
so i flew to uh flute to toronto okay
with a box of 1986 fleer basketball
cards can you put that up there so
people can't see where it originally
came out
at probably 25 50 cents a pack uh went
down in 88 to like 4.99 on closeout and
now is about a 300 000 box of cards so
we opened up that box and then we opened
up ten cases thank you ten cases of a
product called uh 2020 panini flawless
basketball
which is a obviously a modern product
but people are looking for this very
special lebron james card that has the
logo off his jersey from all three teams
he played for cleveland miami and uh the
lakers
so we were there i was up in toronto at
a you know private gathering and um
spent about six hours with uh
with drake uh about four of it opening
up cards and uh two hours of it watching
the oscars and eating so so so this
whole thing with oscars is going on
you're watching it live while you guys
are opening up cards what happened there
when he's uh you know so we met so we um
we
you know took did a promo shot yeah
showed what we're gonna do you and drake
you're saying yeah yeah drake and i and
drake let's just let's not gloss over
the fact that you're spending six hours
of drake opening up cards yeah
by the way can you just show that real
quick can uh you give us permission to
show that or no sure yeah absolutely if
you want to show clipping out of that
you can go uh go on you can go on at ken
golden it's probably all the best videos
yeah go to atkin golden
uh is that at ken golden or who is that
gold yeah that's right there okay so
which one you want to show so show the
um show the one with me holding uh six
uh six cards right there okay go to the
left oh that one right there put the
audio
fine
so there's canon drizzy oh here we go so
right off the bat you can see
that is a uh on the back of the card's a
sticker yeah
so we've got a kareem sticker on the
back let's see
drake now is drake a collector or no uh
drake uh actually in about a minute
opens up his first ever pack of cards
ever in his life ever he said ever in
his life
and how did you guys get hooked up
uh what happened was he was and i'll
tell you when to click it back live as
soon as you see him go to do it and you
know he's got some of his friends there
we're drinking he actually said you know
the first thing he goes okay we're going
to do whoever gets the better packs you
know the next guy has to take a shot and
i'm like
i will not be here if i take 20 shots i
don't know i don't know what you're like
but
that's not going to be uh that's not
going to be me great game he just starts
yeah that's right um but uh drake was
looking for this card and he was doing
it uh by using breakers and breakers are
people who actually open boxes of cards
for you so they do it on youtube they do
it on instagram live they do it on the
other social media apps and you buy into
a break and they'll open the cards and
hope you pull a big card so drake was
doing that with um with a breaker and
then hopped on to my instagram live
about two weeks ago and you know
i went in with somebody and we had a
bunch of cases and we started opening up
cases and what i did was i did what's
called a case war with drake where we
each opened up a box and whoever got the
better cards out of the box
got the other person's box and these are
twenty thousand boxes two three four
five six at a time so um you know it got
a lot of publicity a lot of attention
nice you know and but i i felt
that
you know
you can't it doesn't give the same
effect as if you're there with him
because all you see is champagne popping
and people can be pessimists and they
can say i bet that's a social media guy
typing in i bet it's not really drake
because you know he wasn't showing his
face so
we uh arranged for uh
cases to be brought to him in toronto
and you know i didn't tell anybody
because it's drake i mean he can say no
at the last minute and um you know had
originally contacted um a gentleman who
runs a uh publicity site for trading
card card uh called card porn and he
looped me in and uh we put it together
and we flew up there and um
made it happen and instead of just the
flawless i also during my live i
behind my shelf i have this box of 86
flair and i held it and drake said oh
wow 86 flier michael jordan rookie
that's really cool so i surprised him
and i brought that box with me
to to toronto so i said before we do the
flawless we're going to open up this
flare box and that's really where all of
the
excitement happened and i believe
he is about in a moment to open up his
um
his first pack of cards if we want to go
back um we'll check it out in a second
so he's looking and he didn't want to
touch the cards he you know they're
fragile you know these packs as an
individual pack can sell for seventy
five hundred to ten
per pack one pack and there's 10 uh 36
packs in every box so i said no i'm not
gonna come out here and you know and
have you not do it people want to people
want to see you open the cards you know
let's let's open the cards so um let's
uh let's see what okay oh we missed it
okay
um
here we go
let's take a peek
is this the one he's oh this is his
first time is this the um this is my
pack let's see what he does
oh that's here we go world be free
we'll be free
almost as good as men of world peace no
that's world be free is very bad jerry
sitching
eric
floyd is short this i think is his
fourth pack because uh
what's got
vern fleming and a magic johnson
did you ever open up cards did you ever
open up when i was a kid yeah i loved it
when i was 10 12 years old basically so
he pulled the first pack he opened um
he pulled a um
michael jordan rookie first the first
yeah so i mean i don't know you want to
go um
you know it's got to be up there
somewhere but um basically so yeah so he
like he was hooked and uh
people like a lot of nba players were
joining in uh logan paul uh joined in um
you know other rappers were joining them
people were just going crazy every
everybody uh everybody loved it but
before we broke
um and there's there's a picture of the
jordan uh one of the jordan rookies
that jordan right there is how much if
you can a psa 10 of that goes for what a
psa 10 goes for about in the vicinity of
275 000 to 325 000 per card we pulled
three of that exact card and we pulled
three of the jordan rookie stickers but
also in there you know the reason it's
so iconic is it was the first major
basketball product um in years
so it had the rookie cards of patrick
ewing charles barkley akimolajon clyde
drexler chris mullen isaiah thomas so
many others
so there are so many cards in there that
if they grade properly could be five
thousand to fifteen thousand dollars a
card there's one oddity a a no-name
player named johnny moore but his card
is scarce in a 10. one of them graded a
10 recently sold for 90 000
i mean he's like a common otherwise but
if you can get the card in the 10
because there's only about 60 of them
and everybody wants to get a complete
set with all the cards in a 10 it's very
valuable wow it's kind of crazy it's a
common
but there's only 60 of them to have a
complete set of psa tens
you need this guy to get a 10 and it's a
90k yes nobody could even tell you who
johnny moore is no absolutely not you
just made him famous again it's been
since 84. if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]